all right people this is a
there's a weird one this is a weird one
this is really weird
thanks to that like button by the way if
you clicked on this video you might have
heard i want to share thoughts my first
thought is
somewhere out there
paul dano's riddler is very upset
this is not how he's supposed no more
lies
spider-man supposed to be in morbius
if this is the multiverse do not lie
guys if you haven't heard yet um there's
some things that came out about morbius
and we don't really talk about leaks
anymore on this channel some of you have
noticed and it's not really a leak in my
opinion this is talking about things
that are not in the movie
itself apparently anti-leak so this is
not confirmed yet however all over
social media like all over my twitter
feed all over my instagram feed this was
just populating my sphere now i'm like
you know what i do want to kind of talk
about it a little bit so if you haven't
heard what's being reported right now
keep this in mind i'm actually still
looking forward to this movie i'm
looking forward to morbius regardless of
this information but i do have some
particular feelings about the marketing
of how this is all being handled
everything that generated the biggest
amount of hype for this movie no matter
what you were most looking forward to no
matter what you were most anticipating
it's objective the thing people got most
amped about were the spider-man tie-ins
as you saw in the trailer first images
that came out was jared leto walking and
then behind him was that photo of
spider-man from the ps4 game the tobin
maguire said it's a murderer on it also
you know like the daily bugle newspaper
the oscar building horizon i
am i know reportedly none of these
things are actually in the movie anymore
they've all been edited out of the film
and then on top of that too and this one
strikes me as though that's the oddest
one of them all apparently vultures been
removed from the movie as well this is a
slight spoiler i personally don't know
any of the details about what the scenes
entail reportedly that there's they're
supposed to just be a post-credits scene
featuring vulture and that's it like
there are scenes in the trailer room
like that must be just straight up
removed like the first thing we ever saw
a vulture in the trailer like that must
not be in there because it wouldn't
looks like it wouldn't make sense for a
post-credits scene for for that to be
there so maybe the thing in the new
trailer is what it is i don't know but
then again sony's doing that thing where
they're showing their post credit scenes
in the trailer that's just strange
that's really really strange there's
more to talk about on this as it stands
when i first heard about this my first
reaction is people are gonna get really
upset about that it's one thing to like
manipulate footage in like a marvel
trailer or something like that as we've
seen time and time again now where the
cgi swap out like certain characters one
of the most famous moments is of course
when captain america and hulk are
running in that avengers infinity war
moment something that's just not
featured in the movie at all but you
still get like captain america and hulk
in the movie
that context of that shot is still
happening around that scene whereas in
this this is the thing that they
obviously use to generate hype this is
the thing that they obviously used to
reel people in especially coming off of
the heels of spiderman no way home which
was all about multiversal crossover and
whatnot and to have the audience is
believing that this is what it's going
to be continuing in this is what it's
going to be tying into some more and the
thing that
generated the most hype for this movie
at the end of the day is people going
like which universe does this take place
in a lot of speculation a lot of
questions to which we're just not gonna
get any answers about it whatsoever so
for people who are annoyed by it i
understand because a part of me went
that was dumb if this is true
that's dumb
yeah it's very it is manipulative
because it's not the same thing as just
cgi replacement stuff in like a marvel
trailer or removing something this is a
a specific element that generated
questions that we wanted answers to we
wanted to see how it tied in now in my
opinion if this is indeed true it's
better that this came out now
versus people going to like some people
are not going to learn this information
but it's better that it came out now so
that way people aren't as disappointed
and can just take in the movie morbius
so there's not a riot at the theater
yeah exactly because the people are
going to be upset by it i do think that
these marvel movies should be more
focused on just what it's standalone
pieces especially upon an introductory
character like part of the joke around
this movie is people mainly seem excited
to see it just to see what the
spider-man tie-ins are i know that's not
everybody including myself like i wanted
i just wanted to see a cool vampire b
movie like that's what i wanted to see
as it stands i think this is a bit of a
manipulative tactic it seems like sony's
spider-man universe has been trying to
follow in the marvel cinematic universe
footsteps and is just not fully meeting
that anywhere near and then i've they've
even tried it now with their marketing
and i'm like oh no that's how you do it
well yeah and what confuses me is that
the reports around spider-man know way
home was that sony was largely in charge
of that marketing and they demonstrated
a reasonably conscientious approach to
what to tease from the multiverse what
to keep a secret and this makes me
wonder about the notion of false
advertising moving forward it seems like
they're creating a completely other
layer of plot and world building that's
just not gonna appear and i feel like
that is a little bit different because
when you're misleading us with either
you know taking out characters we know
will be there or you know adding
characters who will still appear you
know doing something that's not going to
actually be a part of your movie and it
might be a part of one of your plans
moving forward is actually deceptive and
might lead people to going i came in
expecting something to do with
spider-man and it's not even here what
gives sony yeah it's not even clear
apparently who which like adrian tombs
this is it's like the rumor is is that
this movie is its own universe that it's
not even tied in like andrew garfield or
toby mcguire's or tom hollands that it's
its own universe i feel like part of
what adds to that rumor too is like
recently director daniel espinoza pull
up the quote here says so in almost all
verses you have spider-man or a
fantastic four or tony stark or morbius
but they will be different in tone
that's not quite the way that the mcu is
approaching the idea but the remaining
to some core truth then you have the
second kind of legend which is about the
totem which is that in all universe
there's a spider-man totem which means
that in all universes there has to be a
spider-man or a spider woman so what
he's saying here is that whatever
universe morbius inhabits has his own
spider-man apparently and he's
technically in the movie because of that
and yeah technically so i imagine that
down they sony would obviously have
plans like the rumor of building up to a
sinister six and you would probably have
more bass and craving the hunter and
what i guess is vulture would also be in
there as well maybe alongside venom so
they want them to eventually cross paths
with spider-man or a spider-man at some
point it's just the the plan moving here
is just
doesn't seem to quite be working like
even for the fact that venom let there
be carnage came out and one of the
biggest things that was most hyped about
was the post-credits scene for venom
finally gonna be able to cross paths
with tom holland and then as you guys
saw in spider-man no way home it
amounted to nothing other than like
let's leave a bit of the goo over there
and that's it like that's that's all it
amounted to they don't actually cross
paths so it's a letdown in terms of what
they're doing to build hype for
spider-man crossover with these
characters i'm like come on these are
characters who derive from the
spider-man world they start off as
antagonists for spider-man we have to
have some clear path that the audience
can get clued in on so maybe with the
madame webb movie is kind of what i'm
imagining is that they're building up
their own like multiverse of madness in
a way maybe stemming from the madame
webb movie itself which would be cool
but then you hear stuff like what matt
smith is saying too about like he came
out recently he was even saying i'm a
little bit confused myself as to even
who my character really is like he's
talking about the history of the
character i'll flash the quote on screen
he said like the script was his bible
and then there's this whole history with
the comic book but the movie didn't seem
to be doing that and part of him is just
still a little bit lost as to who if he
even is luxurious crowns i'm like oh
okay so even main fight
yeah so this whole process just seems to
be uh really becoming messy like i'm
looking forward to craving the hunter
because i really like and admire aaron
taylor johnson quite a bit i imagine
that it's it's probably better that the
word gets out on this now versus when
they go to actually see the movie and
people feel like they've been falsely
misled or just purely baited yeah and
and like people sue over the stupidest
[ __ ] all the time and i'm like this
could lead to i'm like this is where i'm
like no you people were straight up wide
too and if you bought tickets expecting
this you're straight up lied to in those
trailers but all right guys uh what do
you think about this news are you
disappointed in it leave your thoughts
down below you can subscribe click that
bell hit that like button
chase gardner spring has sprung and hey
your last name reminds me of growth and
foliage and new beginnings and
immortality much like a living vampire
you thrive off the world around you
taking in all the colors and molding
them into your own life force chase
follow me on this rabbit hole of whimsy
but hey i hope you're doing well buddy i
hope that you're looking forward to
morbius and not feeling too baited and
switched about the fact that we probably
won't get a spider-man in this movie but
no matter what peter parker's doing i
know that chase is always here and not
too far out of mind and i hope that
you're having a nice start to the
springtime i hope you're feeling that
spirit of new growth love you buddy and
we'll catch you next month be well
[Music]
you